silver lining is that it has exposed
late night hosts just for that the lazy
hats that they are when you take away
the hype the hundreds of employees
writers producers they don't have got
nothing they can't do it here's my
question of the day we're going to move
on and talk about the whole YouTube
landscape and network television
landscape the corona bar it's
essentially forced all late night hosts
now to become youtubers so today in 2020
thanks to karana we are all youtubers
how do you think these hosts stack up
but you know what I know you're gonna
say they suck so I need a more pointed
question specifically which host do you
think stacks up the best without a
massive staff an audience laughter Q's
Colbert Kimmel Noah
[Laughter]
Silver Lining here silver lining
obviously we're not we're not happy
about the coronavirus know is we're not
saying the silver lining is that it has
exposed late night hostess and want to
be late night hosts on CNN on the most
trusted name in news just for that I
wouldn't say talentless but the lazy
hats that they are and that's why we're
trying to do things a little bit
differently definitely here we see that
all of these folks who have all the
staff all this budget they're just
broadcasting from their bathtub now
they're just broadcasting from home and
we decided you know want we can take an
acceptable risk we can come in here we
can quarantine in the office we can
quarantine at home and try to make sure
that you aren't just left out in the
cold because Colbert can't find it
within him as he shuffles past the 15
million annual salary to find a
microphone that he continues to
broadcast so let's go right now to see
in case you don't believe me just how
lazy late night has become to help
prevent the spread of kovat 19 I'm now
shooting the show with a safe minimal
crew of my husband and the creatures of
the forest from that's on NBC my hallway
Tonight Show I'm so excited to be doing
it supposed to
kindergarten is the cubby keyboard
answer to my bathroom
I'm your host Stephen Colbert you're
watching a very special social
distancing edition of The Late Show or
as I now call it the lather show with
scrubbing Colbert sir I'm doing the show
for my hell out in New York and this is
how crazy New York traffic is I'm doing
the show for my living room and I was
still 20 minutes late getting in I'm
utterly loosening up the camera guys
you've isolated yourself okay hey man
don't you ever let me catch you
prescribing in my ward cool never funny
accidentally let me get that never
stumbled across monitor manoa my first
guest tonight as you can see is mr.
bubble followed by a musical performance
by the legendary duo head and shoulders
thanks guys I don't like it I don't want
it shut it off here's something I never
know a lot of people don't realize us
people who haven't performed we've had
this struggle quite a bit when people
are truly taking part and sketches here
because a lot of people here aren't
actors we're kind of fitting them and I
would love you me if they've performed
in rooms for example or in a green
screen room that's supposed to take
place outside yeah where people sort of
talk like this and I go to no listen
people don't see you in a studio in a
green screen room they're going to see
you outside in the forest or they're
going to see you in a crowded mall
that's what we're doing with the green
screen so you need to project right you
need to project the kind of volume and
the kind of intensity that your audience
is expecting given that scenario because
a lot of people get an industry talking
like this
that's what Trevor Noah is doing yeah
he's doing his show as though his wife
is mad in the next room I don't know if
he's married his boyfriend's mad next
room yeah if he catches 20/20 it's just
when you take away the hype the hundreds
of employees writers producers they
don't have got nothing they can't do it
for a reference point by the way well
we're talking about this a single
episode of Trevor Noah show has 21
writers 14 producers Oh cast members
technical crew all that when you look at
the entire staff of a show like
Colbert's you're talking about over a
hundred people and the budget shows have
tens of millions of dollars tonight's
show alone is 75 million dollars 75
million dollars you couldn't find a
camera guy who had more than an iPhone
and sitting laughs like Jimmy Fallon
right in the camera it's terrible when
it's in front of the camera but behind
the camera winners yeah
yeah stop or something - I like this
should have caught them off-guard right
I mean they they knew that something
like this was coming with the
coronavirus out there right didn't have
a technical team that said hey give us
give us half a day we'll set your house
on they do not respect the audience this
is the issue I don't think they respect
the audience you these hosts make
millions some of them make over ten
million dollars a year that's important
to note they could forego half of that
salary yeah to have someone set up a
remote studio by the way this everything
you're ever this entire office the
people out there in the Edit Bay this
entire studio or month we could do all
of that for a fraction of their salary
and here's an important note too because
I'm kind of joking about it but we're
all youtubers they don't stack up well
they're not doing well their views
aren't good when you remove the pay
views it's even less when you remove the
when you remove the algorithms which
favor them because they're advertiser
friendly is even let's see the one thing
we also know about Trevor Noah
horrible horrible design horrible decor
is that modern is it contemporary I
don't know but he has a pube stache so I
guess he's not gay I don't have no I owe
you no work he could just be the man and
he could be the man in the couple you
can just begin okay why are you so
prejudiced that's like assuming that an
uncharacteristically high number of them
get AIDS except less accurate so the
parent companies NBC ABC CBS NBC Vox
right universe Oprah then ABC is Disney
gosh we've been in lawsuits with all of
these lawyers in digital court right now
they're all trying to squeeze YouTube in
Google right trying to get them to favor
these shows because I think they know
that they don't have this stuff to
compete that's why they want to force
shows like this that not just shows like
this but there are plenty take examples
like PewDiePie tell you examples of
whoever there is to turn on a camera and
start live streaming video games and I
think there's there's a race to the
middle right there's a split the
difference with some pre produced
content some decent budget but also
hopefully talent now
by the way hit the notification bell if
you are not joining my club of course
mug club quarantine is the promo code
for the month but the navigation bill
hit all notifications because
subscriptions don't mean a lot and do
subscribe to Crowder bits because that
will be will be uploading a lot of
content extra stuff over this month
here's something else that I think it's
really showcased not only how unfunny
they're I mean I don't think we need a
coronavirus to pull back the curtain on
Sunanda yeah it's not a big reveal no I
don't think so so much of anything for
hers is an improvement yeah it's the
best show she's done in a while because
no one's watching it's what I'm saying
like it's an improvement because if a
horribly unfunny diversity hire screams
alone in a forest so the production
value has gone down and they don't
respect their audience we adore you we
genuinely do we are so grateful they've
also become lazier and this is a civil
awning and hiding their political bias
so yeah Kimmel had former presidential
candidate Pete but gig on to host his
show initially when they were concerned
about the Chinese virus here you go now
this is a strange night for us not only
because this is my first time hosting a
talk show because we are doing it
without a regular studio audience due to
public health concerns over the
coronavirus new staffers canceled the
studio new t-shirts let's do this
together
who's with me here's this big joke watch
full disclosure none of those people are
here but when you don't have a real
audience you have to fake one
just like Trump's inauguration big
toothy smile screw you Pete
screw you hard screw you hard with
someone else's peckers my point I want
nothing about this they're having why
else why would you have P but gig on if
not there's trying to push a political
agenda right now they used to try and
obfuscate a little bit no no we're just
going for comedy really okay so you're a
late-night show and you're just chasing
comedy new thought sub host Pete bucket
that is like no like stand-up comics in
the road who would have the most
horrible opener just to guarantee job
security what's going on or Jimmy Kimmel
actually think speak but gig is funny or
he's pushing a political agenda you
decide which one is more offensive none
of them are good and now here you go
yours is this another Kimmel yeah that's
right he's been interviewing ho from his
home and here you go he is again at one
point you're trying to say well it's not
about left or right it's about being a
human as he cries about Cecil the lion
now he's basically been helping fine
tape awkward campaign commercials that's
what's become Joe Biden what's that how
do you have a New York Mets
supposed to be opening day to be able to
sleep with my wife the filling girl oh
it's the Hat do you think that I'll
brand-new pay you or do you think he
will try to dodge that I don't know I
hope we debate I'm looking forward to
that I don't think you are Joe I don't
think you and your locked off a Cheshire
cat alarm clock mouthpiece really want
to debate Donald Trump it is remarkable
tonight in bed if I want to sleep with
my wife a fish she's a nine-year-old
Philly girl I mean she's a girl you go
from Philly what what happened why'd I
stop
again it is remarkable to me that in all
this I mean what did they have one flab
Donald Trump on right they could have
had all I don't care if they're chasing
the funny I don't care but listen can we
be honest here whether you agree with
President Trump or not by every
available metric it's going to be a
funnier show then it's going to be with
Joe Biden and something else too let's
go to eat not a late-night host but you
know he wants to be juicy gooey that's
right it's always - let's it's likely I
feel like a carnival barker guessing
someone's weight because it's always
different every broadcast with brian
Stelter here it is having Stephen King
on with the chyron when real life is
even scarier than fiction watch this
Stephen thank you for being here I
wonder what what you say about it looks
like an airy denim - lesbian something
Stephen King transitioning - woman well
actually I did imagine it I've heard a
lot about three or four weeks people are
saying to me we're living in a Stephen
King world and all I can say is well I
wish we were really this is a Stephen
Colin second this is a Stephen King
world and truth is stranger than fiction
we're talking about a virus that is at
this point at the point of this
recording nowhere near the magnitude of
a rough flu season you had a film with a
rapist clown troupe stand where 99% of
humor 300 people left with the sniffles
yeah and the reason they are is because
they want to blame it on Donald Trump
they want to act as though well this is
actually worse than the stand this is
actually worse than than it that's right
that's what I was called yeah yeah this
is worse than it because it's Donald
Trump's fault no mention of China by the
way if Stephen King wants to talk about
some sinister plot right some world
order some global conspiracy how about
the people who in the first place and
kill the guy who tried to blow the
whistle could reserve a few pages in
there who do you think stacks up the
best out of all these shows I want you
to tune in for a little bit I'm sorry
just a little bit flip through CNN Fox
News ABC NBC CBS all the late night
shows and tell me who you think is doing
the best job adapting right now and is
this is important because it's not the
strongest animal that survives it's the
animal who can most effectively adapt
and we've consistently tried to do that
and be ahead of the curve not because
we're afraid of going away but because
we really do live to serve you guys we
always think hey listen we have been
supported from the ground up from
viewers you have created this show we
weren't thrust upon you by a network who
decided to put us on timeslot that
people were watching anyway and so we've
had to earn our keep we've had to earn
your viewership these people don't now
you see how lazy they are and that's why
of course we're offering this month the
whole month free bug Club month
hashtag bug Club quarantine or doing
Monday through Thursday evening shows
available on YouTube in front of the pay
while we're adding three shows a week
and got a lot of programs let's schedule
every Monday Wednesday Friday April 10
a.m. Eastern and Crowder bits Apple and
we are trying to give you as much
content as possible and I appreciate a
lot of you saying you know look out for
your health I'm treating it like two a
days I'm sleeping right I am eating
right and I'm very very unhappy but as
long as I am serving you because all you
have this is the reason we're doing this
because I should i watch late-night
religiously I have to yeah it's not much
you don't know how dark it's inside my
head sometime okay and so because of
that I was going this is all this is all
this is all everyone has out there we
have to give them more and so we're
going to give you everything we have
this month because I know a lot of you
are out of work I know a lot of you run
businesses that may not open up again
anytime soon
and so if I have to work 12 14 16 hour
days for a month you know what I'll take
it if it helps you guys and then I'll
have a long weekend hey you enjoyed this
show subscriber hit the notification but
I'm come it's cold in here so I'm
covering I'm covering my nips hit all
notifications on the notification Bell
because apparently notification
scription don't mean a whole lot look
their video what they're playing in
boxes those happen in quarter bucket
their videos playing in boxes you should
click one of them maybe one of them is a
mystery box could cut glass with these
things